along with providing companionship pet
ownership has long been known to have
other benefits according to the Centers
for Disease Control studies have shown
that having a pet can increase Fitness
lower stress and even improve blood
pressure and cholesterol levels and
animals are now playing another
important role in medicine providing an
avenue of treatment for people suffering
from serious mental health issues we
visited a farm in Massachusetts where
helping animals helps people heal like
animals better than people I've heard a
lot of people say that yeah why they're
non-judgmental they love you
unconditionally five days a week
Heather Moyer tends to alpacas goats
rabbits and chickens it may look like
fun but Moyer comes here to the
cultivate care farm to do serious work
since July she has cared for these
rescue animals as part of her treatment
for schizophrenia I just feel more
peaceful the world wouldn't be the same
without them you know Moyer is just one
of about a hundred clients at the bolton
massachusetts farm which offers
treatment for all mental health
diagnoses as well as autism disorders
and addiction we've worked with children
as young as four and clients as old as
in their 80s and the entire gamut within
that some sessions can include cuddling
a furry friend while talking to a
licensed mental health professional like
cultivates clinical director Deb Madera
a counselor with 17 years of experience
do we know why animals sort of knock
down these walls and make therapy easier
in that regard there's the cuddle
hormone and when you spend up to 20
minutes with an animal with your hands
on them you can feel more relaxed and
feel more comfortable and your anxiety
comes down and then it's a lot easier to
deal with your issues and talk about
things that might be uncomfortable if
you're not feeling so anxious working
with animals while working on well-being
is based on green care farming popular
across Europe
Andrew lapin study the model while
getting his master's in mental health
counseling I thought this is wonderful
I'll go work someplace like that there
must be several places doing it and it
turns out there's not
turns out if you have $20,000 a month
with a six-month minimum commitment you
can go to live on a therapeutic farm but
that's so incredibly inaccessible for so
many people that's what inspired him to
open cultivate what were the biggest
hurdles as you were getting this started
one was just kind of educating folks
that said we're not just a petting zoo
right this is a medical appointment
you're working with a licensed therapist
or a soup intern under supervision but
this is a professional practice and to
was convincing the insurance company
that the same sharing with them that
this is an effective means of treatment
so that we can become as accessible as
possible and not just a private pay
clinic not having to pay out of pocket
is a bonus for Lisa
Samara wera her ten-year-old daughter
Livie comes here once a week okay to
ease her anxiety how did you feel when
you went and had some of the more
traditional therapy it didn't help at
all because it was making me more
nervous than I already was lisa says
Livie seems to be responding better to
this alternative therapy it's not just
focused all exclusively on her it's also
working with the animals who have their
own anxieties and fears and problems and
I think that helps tremendously
you're shaking your head you're great
yeah a lot of the animals here don't
really like humans and they get really
nervous
so I really want to try to like make
them get more used to it by hanging out
with them and giving them like treats
and stuff and they have a lot of the
same things that I get nervous about a
2007 study found that animal assisted
therapy was moderately effective in
improving autism spectrum symptoms
medical difficulties behavioral problems
and emotional well-being
maybe that's why therapy animals have
popped up everywhere
from Lilu the pig at San Francisco
International Airport to these llamas on
the campus of UCSF Mission Bay another
trend you can stay in plank position if
you have a goat on you is goat yoga take
one more deep breath here what a good
boy
Nina a comb fry is an adjunct professor
at the University of Denver's Institute
for human animal connection
she says health providers are catching
on the practitioner is starting to
realize oh I can do more effective work
in this more natural environment the
therapist still uses their typical
clinical decision-making there the
strategies that they've been trained in
within their scope of practice but
simply enhance their work through the
elements of the inclusion of the animal
the additional relationships the
opportunity for moving around for
touching for problem solving and having
real interactions but just not with a
human which can feel quite intimidating
at cultivate that opportunity came with
a major investment Deb Madera and her
husband emptied their 401k to buy this
place why do you believe in this model
so much it works in a way that nothing
I've ever done in the mental health
field has and I wanted to make sure that
it continued to work for people and we
could reach more and more people and
help them get healthy people like
Heather Moyer who has found that caring
for these rescues has helped her care
for herself have you noticed a
difference in yourself since you started
coming yeah what's been the biggest
change me you're looking forward to
doing something interesting every day
something good to wake up for and
there's so many good things to come from
it I think it's important to remember
it's the cost and accessibility that
they have there yes but they are using
traditional methods I mean even just
Heather obviously she's dealing with
schizophrenia and that means medication
also but this helps in the therapy I
love what that Mandara said that the
animals activate the cuddle hormone oh
yeah no I
had one I wish lot there were llamas on
my college campus yeah you know what
just tells us we need to get out there
and experience nature and I'm rattle a
little right I'm willing to bring
Barkley in every Saturday Berkeley an
Einstein